what you've got here is a Ryan angle
triangle what makes it a triangle
it's got how many sides three very good
and what makes it right angled well one
of the angles is how big what's the size
how many degrees yeah ninety degrees
very good so what I'd like us to do I
left my color of here is let's mark in
that ninety degrees I'm gonna put it
here and your diagram is going to look a
bit different to mine but the three
sides I want us to name them and we're
gonna name them in this particular order
and we like to use letters to name it I
mean I suppose I could call these like
you know John and Elliot and Anne but
that just takes forever
so I'm mathematicians are famously lazy
we're always looking for fast ways to do
things so I wanted to name these three
sides just by letters a B and C but
please do it this way in increasing
order of lengths so your shorter side
make that a your longest side make that
C and you can use your ruler of course
to check which one is which and then the
in-between one the middle they call that
B okay so for me that looks like so okay
fantastic now I can see you're a I can
see the B I can see the see just watch
out that when you draw this new set of
shapes around this one you've got to be
quite careful these shapes here I don't
just want them to be any old shapes I
want them to be squares square square
square okay so the way I did this the
way I worked it out was and if you got
it wrong no big deal that's what rubbers
before okay I rubbed things off all the
time if you take this length a for
instance maybe on your diagram it's like
four and a half centimeters long I don't
know how long it is because you've all
got different ones okay
measure that four and a half centimeters
and then draw a new line that's going
away from that which is also four and a
half centimeters do one of the other
edges and then you can connect them up
and now you've got a whole square and
all the lengths are four and a half okay
try to keep everything nice and
right-angled that'll make sure your
squares look good use the ruler to help
you and then just repeat this process
for all the others you're gonna end up
with three squares on those three sides
if this boys looking for us you're going
to do something which is really easy on
your page and really hard on my
whiteboard so let me ask you to look up
even if you're not finished with all of
your diagram yet that's totally okay oh
you'll get plenty of time while I'm
drawing here's what I'd like you to do
can you see how we've got one two three
squares right three squares and we
actually know this size if you have
another color use that but if you don't
it's no big deal she's the same one this
square over here has a side length of a
and because the square these are all a
aren't they so what's the area of this
square no one told me oh yeah go ahead
hey now if I wanted to find the
perimeter I'd say a plus a plus a plus a
which would be for a if I wanted to find
a perimeter can tell me someone told me
how much space does it take up what's
its area not the length of round but the
area inside any takers
hmm yeah well you reckon a squared in
fact that's why we call a squared a
squared because it's the shape of it's
the area of that square that you're in
okay so that's a squared all right this
one down the bottom what's it called B
squared very good one last one at the
top it's the biggest one and it's C
squared happy times okay now here comes
the tough bit I want you to take your
piece of paper that's tough for me it's
easy for you and I actually want you to
spin it around so that C this big square
whatever your biggest square is your C
squared okay I want that C squared to
look like this so it's flat on the
bottom of your page so you're gonna have
a new diagram where C squared is here
and then the triangle sort of sitting on
top like this does this make sense can
you turn around why watch very carefully
for this part okay I'm gonna ask you to
put all pins out of your hands because
what you're about to do I want you to
make sure you get the steps right you're
gonna pick up your ruler and you're
gonna draw over the top of your squares
in a particular way watch carefully I'm
gonna use this color because nice and
dark this is B squared this one here
this is where all the action is going to
happen okay so watch it
carefully I'm going to put all ruler
right up through B squared right up the
middle like this okay so I want you to
notice that ruler is going straight up
it's a vertical line I'm about to draw a
vertical line and I've lined it up with
this square down the bottom your big
square you okay with that can you put
your ruler in exactly the same spot as
mine so it's lined up with C squared and
it's going straight up yep okay pen or
pencil in hand we're gonna draw a line
straight down B squared like so I'm
gonna chop it into this piece like so
all right so you've just drawn a line
right up B squared and chopped it into a
piece like so yeah yeah it looks a bit
of like weird random line doesn't it
where is it going it's a lot of diagonal
it's not an edge it just looks weird
doesn't it don't worry its weirdness
will become very important in a second
okay next part pens down look up again
we made a vertical line with our ruler
before now we're going to make a
horizontal line let me show you where
it's gonna go it's on B squared again
this pink one and it's going to look
exactly like this okay so can you see
it's horizontal and instead of starting
from this bottom corner it starts from
the right-hand corner do you see that so
it goes from the right-hand corner it
goes straight across in fact I'm even
going to draw from that corner and I'm
just gonna draw a horizontal there like
so okay it's a bit messy I even went
onto the whiteboard but that's okay all
right so you drew two lines and these
two lines have divided up B squared into
how many pieces four piece is very good
you can see them there okay now what I'd
like you to now do is pick up your pair
of scissors that you have okay now
you're going to cut out your entire
shape I gave the whole thing okay but in
addition to cutting out a square and B
squared + C spend also the triangle see
how we put these extra lines on that B
squared I want you to cut those lines as
well can you do that for me so you're
going to cut out your whole shape you're
eventually gonna put this into your book
in your a four piece of cardboard
probably won't fit okay but importantly
these lines that we
put on to be squared you're also going
to cut all the way up and across there
so you get four pieces out of this guy
does that make sense
so get head and do that you're all about
to do this slightly differently to me
okay it's actually really important
you'll see why in a minute so what is
Pythagoras's theorem Pythagoras's
theorem is about a relationship between
these three squares that we've drawn on
the edges on the sides of this right
angle triangle let me show you what the
relationship is a squared B squared C
squared watch me I'm going to rearrange
the reason why we did all this weird
cutting here is so I could rearrange
this B squared here's how I'm gonna do
it let's see if I remember how okay I
think this guy is gonna go right down
yeah I think this one should fit there
where's this one gonna go I'm gonna
slide it down and my last one goes
across here fit please yay it worked
okay
now you might notice what we've done is
we've moved around all the pieces of B
squared from up here and fit them into
the corners of C squared you're about to
do this yourself okay and you can see
I've left like a hole in the middle of
that big square and coincidentally not
coincidentally my last square in here
just fits over the top now I have to
apologize for the fact that my
construction is not very good you can
decide where the mine is better than
yours or not but what have we done here
yeah dear Krishna okay so let's take all
of what we just said and put it in two
because you don't really want to draw
this diagram every single time you want
to it's a bit of a mess with all the
cardboard all that kind of thing this
green guy here is the small one right
and we said it's area was a sweat right
now when you add it to this pink square
which was which was that one that was B
squared I know I had to rearrange it to
fit in but it's still the same square
right it's just in pieces what you end
up getting
that all of these are equal to the big
square the one that we didn't touch from
the beginning okay this guy here this
relationship between the sides of a
right angle angle that's what we call
Pythagoras's theorem now here's the
important thing and you're about to do
this right you might think ah mister we
just did like he prepared this earlier
clearly and so he was in Newark with his
particular triangle but it doesn't just
work with my particular triangle it will
work with all of yours as well that's
why I asked you to draw all different
ones now at this point it's going to be
tricky because you're all in lots of
pieces right now and I have done this
before but I want to help you guys to
try and rearrange it and fit all your
pieces together mrs. Liza's there as
well and so you can get this
rearrangement happening in your own
diagram so have a go put them together
and if it works for you call us over or
if you're having trouble calls over and
we'll help